à paris deux gérants de serveurs
internet à caractère pédophile ont été
interpellés le réseau internet c'est une
sorte de banque de données mondiale qui
permet de stocker et d'échanger des
milliards d'informations mais non de les
contrôler et encore moins de les
censurer
patrice pollet ils en ont beaucoup parlé
longuement discuté lors de ce 5e salon
mondial du réseau internet discuter de
ça du sexe qui envahit le réseau des
milliers de web de service porno qui
vont finir affirment certains
professionnels par m internet au ban de
la société est dans le collimateur des
juges d'instruction ces choses existent
dommageable y compris à la réputation
d'internet quand ce que je peux affirmer
manière très ferme et très forte c'est
que l' usage d'internet de manière très
très très majoritaire en dehors de ce
sujet
aujourd'hui les professionnels
pourvoyeur d'informations sur internet
se disent conscients de la situation et
s'est volontairement qu'il propose d'en
restreindre l'utilisation pour les
enfants par exemple les parents pourront
sélectionner très précisément les
contenus que les enfants vont pouvoir
vont pouvoir choisir ça se fera avec une
souris un clavier quelques manipulations
sans micro ordinateurs et puis on croit
complètement sécurisé le contenu que la
famille elle pourra lire et accéder sur
internet
mais bien entendu tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord pour la majorité des
utilisateurs internet doit rester un
réseau libre qui se joue des frontières
et des états